everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem reconstruct itinerary
this is a pretty difficult problem but
it's doable if you have a good
understanding of graphs and graph
traversals especially dfs which we're
going to be using in this problem but
we're given a list of airline tickets
and these tickets are basically a graph
edge we have a from and a two so
basically a source and a destination and
it connects two nodes together in this
case the nodes are going to represent
airports or cities and basically using
this list of tickets we want to
reconstruct the itinerary and basically
what that means is we want to
reconstruct the flight history of a
person who had this list of tickets all
of the tickets belong to someone who
departed from jfk so no matter what this
is going to be our starting edge in our
graph so basically if you take a look at
this picture we're always going to be
starting at jfk so we're pretty much
guaranteed that jfk is going to be a
node in our graph they also tell us that
we can assume all tickets form at least
one valid itinerary so basically we're
guaranteed that there is a solution and
in the solution that we create we have
to use every single ticket exactly once
and there's one last thing that they
tell us there could be multiple
solutions and if there are multiple
solutions we want to return the one that
has a smaller lexical order basically
the one that comes first in sorted order
and you can't really tell that from this
example because there's really only one
solution but let's take a look at
another so here we have a different
graph let's say you know a was jfk in
this context i'm just using abc to keep
it simple but we're starting at a we
could uh you know we want to go over
every single edge basically each edge
represents a ticket we want to go over
every single edge and we want the
history of the destinations to be our
result so you know let's say we're
creating our result a is going to be
first and then you know what we could do
is we could say okay let's visit uh c
first right we get to c and then we go
back to a right from c so
you know what we could say is okay we
first go to a then go to c then go back
to a and then we go to b and then we go
back to a from b and then that would
leave our result looking something like
this that's one possible solution but
the other solution would have been to go
to b first and then go to c what that
would have looked like is a
b
a
c a now which one of these has a smaller
lexical order which one of these comes
first in sorted order well the first
character a is the same but the second
character could be b or c which one of
these comes first b comes first so of
course of these two we would prefer the
second one we would return the second
order as our result so that's something
to keep in mind and the way we can
actually handle this is going to be
pretty easy i'll show you how we can you
know make sure that we return the
smaller lexical order result now this
example is very simple because there's
really only one you know ordering that
we could possibly create and to get that
ordering what we could do is just run
dfs starting at jfk we know we're always
going to start at jfk we create a dfs
running on this and you know using this
dfs technically we are allowed to visit
multiple the you know the same node
multiple times as i showed in the
example just a moment ago but what we
can't do is go over the same edge
multiple times we can't reuse one of our
tickets but in this case if we run a dfs
starting at jfk you know what we'll get
is jfk first then this one then this one
then this one and then this one so
there's really only one ordering and you
can see that that's the output for this
example the expected output and so
that's what we can return but if we of
course had multiple choices like this or
you know adding a bunch more edges and
we still have to go over every single
edge and we have to return the smallest
lexical order you know let's see how we
can do that algorithm so like i
mentioned you really have to have a good
understanding of graphs to be able to
solve this problem i'm going to assume
you kind of already know dfs and the
basics of graphs so what we're going to
use to do the traversal on this graph in
the first place is you know create an
adjacency list of course we're already
given the list of edges but we have to
actually create an adjacency list out of
that to be able to traverse over the
graph and the way we're going to be you
know creating this adjacency list is
just going to be by using a hashmap
we're going to map every single node to
the you know every single source rather
to the possible destinations that we can
take and the easiest way to build an
adjacency list is just kind of iterate
over the input which is tickets in this
case right it's a list of source
destination pairs so what we would do is
say okay jfk has a san francisco sfo at
least i assume that's san francisco uh
and then it also has a second one
atlanta atl and we can start adding
those to our adjacency list like this is
the list this is the source right so
from jfk we can travel to these two
cities but what i'm going to tell you
right now is that we should have this
list in sorted order because we're going
to be running dfs and as we run dfs
we're going to start at the first
possible source that we could visit from
jfk right we're going to try sfo and
maybe we find a result starting at sfo
in that case we could return that as the
result but what if it turned out that
maybe we could have also found a result
of you know going to atlanta first
rather than sfo in that case this is the
result that we would prefer because it
comes first in sorted order so what we
want is for each of these lists to be in
sorted order and we could build the
adjacency list and then sort each of
these lists independently but the easier
way to do it is actually just to sort
the input and i'll show you why because
the way we're going to be sorting the
input is by doing this these are pairs
of values right the first uh value is
going to be the first key that we're
going to use to sort so you know these
two jfks would be next to each other but
then if there's a tie between the first
value then we want to use the second
value as our sorting keys so among these
two which is going to come first sfo or
atl of course atl because it comes first
you know that's just something to keep
in mind so if we have this in sorted
order then our adjacency list will be
sorted by default right and i'm actually
going to build this adjacency list now
assuming that this thing is in sorted
order or at least i'm going to be going
through the sorted order version of this
uh list of tickets so first is going to
be atl and it has jfk as one of its
destinations so let's do that and atl
also has sfo as one of its destinations
so let's add that next we have jfk it
has atlanta as one of its destinations
and it also has sfo as one of its
destinations and then lastly we have sfo
which only has one destination which is
atl so let's add that so now we're gonna
start running our dfs so let's focus on
the picture now so we're gonna be
starting at jfk you know we have two
outgoing edges from jfk we could go to
sfo or we could go to atl which one are
we going to decide well we're going to
look at our adjacency list and see which
one comes first well atl comes first so
let's visit atl so we're going to go
along this edge and now we're going to
be at atl and when we do that we're
actually going to remove atl from our
adjacency list at least temporarily for
now and by the way as we you know go
along this we're also going to be
building our result our result is just
going to be you know the travel history
of these airports we know initially we
start at jfk and right now we just
visited atl so that's going to come next
okay now from atl we have two outgoing
edges we could go to sfo or we could go
to jfk which one are we going to decide
well let's see which one comes first in
sorted order it's jfk so let's go to jfk
next so we're going back to jfk so we
visited both of these two edges and
let's remove jfk as an
as a destination from atlanta and in our
result now let's add jfk again because
we started at jfk then we went to
atlanta then we're back at jfk now from
jfk we only have one outgoing edge
remaining sfo and that you can tell from
our adjacency list as well so let's pop
sfo now we're at sfo let's add that to
our result as well now from sfo we only
have one destination it makes things
easy for us that's atlanta so let's pop
atlanta from here let's go along that
edge and let's add atl to our result and
from atl now we only have another a
single edge outgoing it's to sfo so
let's pop sfo travel along that edge and
add sfo to our result so this was a
valid way because we just visited every
single edge how exactly do we know we
visited every single edge though well
our result is going to be keeping track
of all of the nodes that we visited in
our graph right not the edges we know
every time we visit one of the edges
we're going to be adding another node to
our result and we know that we actually
initially start with a single node which
is jfk before we even travel along any
edges right we start at jfk so basically
we know we are finished when the length
of our results array is equal so i'll
write it out is equal to the length of
our tickets plus
1. so down here you can see when length
of result is equal to length of tickets
plus one that's how we know that we are
done the plus one comes from the fact
that we already start with a single uh
node in our result array and then every
other node comes from traveling along
one of the edges in our graph so that's
the main idea now in this example it was
kind of simple for us because the first
you know solution ended up working the
first path that we tried ended up
working but if it didn't suppose we
actually had a graph that looked like
this one and let's say we started at the
a node in this case we have two choices
of where we could go we could go to c
first or we could go to b first we're
going to choose b because it comes first
in lexical order compared to c so we
travel along this edge and we end up
visiting the b okay well now we're stuck
here there's no outgoing edges from b we
can't even get back to a so what we
found is we tried to be greedy we tried
to take the first character that came
right the the first the alphabetical
character but it didn't work out for us
so we end up backtracking we say okay
we're actually not going to travel along
this edge at least just yet we're
actually going to travel to the c first
even though it comes after in order
compared to the b just because we know
that at least here we might be able to
create a valid path so we go to c then
we go back to a and then we go to b so
basically what we
realized from this example is that
sometimes in some of the cases we're
going to have to backtrack so we might
go along an edge and realize that it
doesn't work and then we're going to
have to reverse our decision and then
travel along a different edge so that's
something we're gonna have to keep in
mind let's actually jump into the code
in a second and stay tuned because it's
actually gonna be pretty tricky but
let's discuss the time complexity of
this solution and since i mentioned we
are going to be doing some form of
backtracking the overall time complexity
to run a dfs on the entire graph in the
worst case it would be like a v plus e
right basically the size of the graph
but since we are backtracking
potentially for every single edge that
exists in the graph the overall time
complexity is going to be you know the
size of the graph squared and you know
since we know that the number of edges
is actually going to be you know
approximately the same or greater than
the number of vertices we can actually
think of this as pretty much being e
squared as the time complexity and as
the memory complexity we can consider it
to be big o of the number of edges one
because we're going to be storing it in
our adjacency list and when we do the
function recursively this could be the
size of the call stack in the worst case
so this is the time complexity this is
the memory complexity now let's code it
up okay so let's code it up we are going
to first create our adjacency list we
are going to map every single source
node to an empty list initially so let's
go through every single source
destination in our input which is
tickets and just map the source to an
empty list for now and then let's
actually build the adjacency list so
let's go through every source
destination in our tickets and then say
for this source we want to append to it
this destination and that's really all
the pre-work that we have to do now we
actually get into our dfs where we are
going to be passing in some source node
and then running dfs on it seeing if we
can actually find a valid path and then
updating our result accordingly right
our result is basically going to be that
path that we found that is valid and in
lexical order now we know that we have a
starting point in our results initially
we start at jfk and we actually don't
have to pass this variable into our dfs
because our dfs is declared inside of
the outer function but now for the base
case of this dfs one is that we find our
solution how do we know if we find our
solution again well if the length of the
result is exactly equal to the length of
the tickets plus one and in that case
we're going to return true saying that
we did find a valid path now one of the
cases where we can't find a valid path
is if the this source that we're at is
not actually in our adjacency list what
that means is that this source does not
have any outgoing edges from it in that
case we can go ahead and return false
that means we can't find a valid path
okay so now what we want to do is
actually iterate through all of the
neighbors of our current
source node right so for this source
node we're going to go through all of
the adjacent neighbors and let's
actually call it v so for the input that
we're given this source we're going to
go through all of its neighbors we're
going to call that neighbor the v and we
actually want to enumerate over this and
basically what enumerate is going to do
for us is going to allow us to iterate
over the index at the same time as the
actual
value which is the vertex but what
you're about to see is actually we're
going to be modifying the adjacency list
as we iterate through it right because
if we visit this v
vertex this node then we want to remove
it we want to remove the i index from
the adjacency list currently but we
can't really
you know update a list as we iterate
through it that's not really good to do
it in many cases it's not even allowed
so you know rather than iterating over
this i'm going to actually create a
temporary array of that so i'm going to
create a copy of it and in python you
can do that just like this just pass
that list into a list constructor and
that'll create a copy for us and then
let's iterate over that copy instead
because we want to be updating the
actual adjacency list because that's
what's going to be used in future
recursive calls okay so we're we're
visiting one of the neighbors this is
that neighbor what we want to do is pop
it from our adjacency list so let's get
the adjacency list of the source and
then pop it so we're popping the i index
and once we pop it we also want to
append it to our result what we're
saying is this is our current path so we
can add that v that vertex to our result
and then what we want to do is run our
i'm just gonna you know leave that as a
placeholder for now and then if that dfs
ends up returning true then we can
return true and then stop the function
call because we're just looking for one
path and we will know that that path is
the smallest lexical order one because
we sorted our tickets which i just
realized i forgot to do so let's
actually do that up above before we
build our adjacency list let's not
forget to actually sort our tickets
by default in python this will
sort the tickets based on the pair
basically the logic that i summarized
earlier in the video but in some
languages you might have to you know
customize that source comparator okay by
jumping back to the logic down here so
this is the decision that we're making
kind of in our back tracking if we find
that it returns true that's great but if
it doesn't return true then we have to
backtrack this decision so what what we
just did up above what we did was we
popped this so instead of popping let's
insert it back into our adjacency list
so at this index we want to add v back
to it and we you know added this to the
end of our result so now let's actually
pop from the end of our result to remove
that right basically reversing this
decision that we make and then making a
new decision on the next iteration of
the loop now of course it's possible
that you know down this decision you
know down this recursive call we don't
find a solution so in that case we end
up returning false from this function
but we know we are guaranteed at least
one solution so we know that when we
actually called this dfs function which
i'm going to do right now called the dfs
and we know that the parameter we want
to pass in is jfk that's always going to
be our initial source node so we pass in
dfs and then what we end up returning is
going to be our result and of course
this time it wasn't really the logic i
misnamed one of the variables i don't
know why i named it time it should be
temp okay now let's rerun this and i
left our placeholder dfs as it is we
forgot to pass in the variable we know
that the variable is v
v is the node that we're going to be
passing in okay let's try this again
okay awesome now it actually works you
can see that it's pretty efficient on
the left this is a pretty challenging
problem but i think that this solution
while it's difficult it is also doable
for a hard problem so i really hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching